– Das sind so viele
Stellenanzeigen für Praktika.
Ich kann mich gar nicht entscheiden.
– Dann entscheide ich. Lies vor!
– Okay, zum Beispiel hier:
„Zuverlässige, zielorientierte und flexible
Praktikanten im Bereich Grafikdesign.
Junges, motiviertes Team
sucht Verstärkung.
Du willst Erfahrungen sammeln
und hast Interesse an Design?
Dann schick uns deine Bewerbung
an …“ und so weiter.
– Ich hab nicht alles verstanden.
– Es ist eine Anzeige für ein Praktikum
im Bereich Grafikdesign.
– Und was macht man da im Praktikum?
– Ich weiß nicht genau. Aber ich finde,
dass sich das gut anhört.
– Was hast du noch?
– Eine Stellenanzeige von einem
Architekturbüro.
Die suchen auch Praktikanten.
– Architekt klingt nach einem Beruf,
der Spaß macht.
– Ja, aber ich weiß nicht,
ob ich das kann. Hier:
„Zuverlässige, kreative Praktikantin im …“
– Mit wem sprichst du?
– Ich? Ach so, ich übe nur ein paar Sätze
für ein Bewerbungsgespräch.
– Du schaffst das.
Hilfst du mir beim Essen?
– Ja, ich komm gleich.
Ich muss Schluss machen.
– Okay. Du schreibst die Bewerbung
für das Architekturbüro!
– Und du schreibst die Bewerbung
für die Schauspielschule!
– Ich weiß nicht.
Ich wollte doch die Ausbildung
zum Zweirad…
– Kannst du ja trotzdem.
Du sollst es wenigstens versuchen!
– Okay.
– Okay. Tschüss!